hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
what she's saying
in that third section
is that traditional moral theory has
thought of things
in in these terms at with two poles
pull the cell for the individual
and the pull of the everybody else
the universal
you had
sometimes you know like if you take kant
for example what does kant say you have
to be able to universalize
what it is that you're
saying you ought to do
if you can't universalize it then it's
not really a duty for you
you can't make it a duty
if you can universalize it and you can
will it to be a universal law then it
tells you what your your actual duty is
what would be what is standing in the
way of that your own selfishness right
your own tendency to make an exception
for yourself
what about with bentham
the greatest happiness principle right
greatest happiness of everybody
egos says
forget the whole
you know what how is it going to pan out
best for me
you might even have certain
understandings of virtue ethics that
sort of fit into this this thing as well
what's in between between everybody
and the just one person
the self well this whole she calls a
matrix
of
relationships
and she thinks that traditional moral
theory has not looked closely enough at
this and focused on this as a should
have
so she says uh between this dome the
domain between the the self is the ego
as the self-interested individual and
the universal everyone others in general
there's something else that has been
overlooked and what is that the
intermediate realm she calls this
of family relations so family fits in
there
what else fits in there friendships
um
group ties
neighborhood
especially from the point of view of
women she says
all that's been overlooked
yeah you know and there's there's
something to that again when we look at
arizona we'll see that aristotle had
some room in there after that
but
you know does can't have anything like
that does bentham have anything like
that not really as a matter of fact
bentham actually when he was talking
about benevolence didn't he contrast a
too narrow view of benevolence only
looking out for your own neighborhood
your own group your own family with a
universal benevolence
so even when there's some
acknowledgement of that there's there's
not enough acknowledgement
held would be saying
how important is this this
area well you know at the beginning of
the semester
every time that i ask maris students
about you know what really matters to
you where does your happiness lie
inevitably some of you say family
or your friends
so you think at least
men and women both
because the the answers actually come
almost equally for men and women don't
they that this matrix of relationships
is something that's particularly
important for you
and you would want moral theory to be
able to tell you why
or how to distinguish good relationships
from bad relationships
so she says this this region of what she
calls particular others it's a distinct
domain
where what can be seen to be artificial
and problematic are the very egoistic
self and universal all others this is
where we really live she thinks
in this domain
this is where we really find ourselves
in our relationships with other people
it's kind of a
according to her it's kind of an
illusion to think that first we exist as
isolated atomistic
totally individual selves and only then
find ourselves in relationships and you
know if you think about this for just a
moment
is that true
how did you come to be in this world
as a human being
a little baby
mom and dad so you have at least two
people that you're related to
right
and um that's you know the core of
family
and did you choose mom and dad
that doesn't even make sense does it
i mean under what weird science fiction
thing could we have like the little baby
choosing okay i'm going to be born out
of this family here or something like
that that doesn't work that's contingent
you didn't choose that
and then with your mom and dad did
anything else come as part of the
package that you didn't have control
over
their relationships their relationships
with like who
like everyone else around them like the
rest of the family or maybe they're like
friends that
yeah their their neighborhood i mean
they settled down in one particular
place you grew up there or maybe you
traveled around because
you know
your mom or dad had to move around
people you interacted with who you
didn't even know they were and they
probably got told they were uncles and
aunts and they actually weren't uncles
or aunts or even cousins you know
all this sort of stuff piles up and all
that is taking place in this
intermediate sphere
and that that helps to make you what you
are this is where you come from
you don't come from just an isolated
individual
all by yourself you come from a context
this sounds a lot like mcintyre though
doesn't it at the beginning of the
semester
and that's that's a very important thing
to
to look at so she says um
in the domain of particular others the
self is already constituted to an
important degree by relations with
others you are
in this respect your relations with
other people
you you become the way that you interact
with other people
these relations may all may be much more
salient and significant than the
interests of any individual self in
isolation the others in the picture are
not the all others or every one of
traditional moral theory they're not
what a universal point of view or a view
from nowhere would provide they're
actual people who you are connected with
in some way
neighbors
suitemates or roommates hallmates
whatever it is that you
live with here in the dorms i'm not sure
what your
living setup is like um friends friends
of friends
family sometimes you can't get away from
so
what's the importance of this
well this this relationship idea is key
and
think about the way in which we view
relationships
are relationships valuable only because
you've got two isolated people who then
connect up with each other and they're
each getting something out of it and the
relationship will last so long as they
do some relationships are like that
right
business relationships
you don't want to get too friendly with
the people that you're connected with
with business relationships because you
might have to break it off if they
become unprofitable
or they they screw you over
but is that any way to look at say
familial relationships
is that the way a family relationship
bought to go where anybody can say ah i
don't like this deal i'm going to walk
away
the family relationship comes to take on
ideally in this
a sort of importance of itself where the
people find themselves in the
relationship
the relationship is not just about what
each of them is getting out of it
the relationship becomes something that
has its own value
in the ethics of care
and intrinsic value so
she says self-development apart from
their relation may be much less
important than the satisfactory
development of the relation
think about a really good friendship
um
you don't measure a really good
friendship just by what you yourself get
out of it and what the other person gets
out of it there's something in the
friendship that goes beyond
the two of you and brings the two of you
together
the friendship itself
developing that maintaining it deepening
it that becomes something valuable for
its own sake not just for the sake of
what you yourself get out of it that's
part of why we can get so hurt
when
we think we're in that kind of
relationship
and it turns out that the other person
has only been looking at it
instrumentally
that's why we feel so betrayed when
somebody else you know says ah
i'm going to use this for something else
she's again she's on to something very
important here the ethics of care has
something
to tell us how can we evaluate
relationships she gives us some examples
relationships can be evaluated as
trusting or mistrustful
not all relationships are good
relationships right
mutually considerate or selfish some
relationships good relationships are
mutually considerate bad relationships
one person is getting taken advantage of
uh harmonious or stressful now of course
you might like stressful relationships
you know some people actually enjoy a
conflict but most of us don't do we
most of us would prefer to have
harmonious relationships
i i know some people who like you know
have relationships for the sake of
having conflict that they like to have
in their life but i don't think that's
most of us
where trust and consideration are
appropriate she says which is not always
we can find ways to foster them but
understanding and evaluating
relationships requires us to look at
relationships between actual persons
they have models that we can look to to
have criteria that's coming from the
relationships that we experience
so here's the the
conclusion she draws
to be adequate
moral theories must pay attention to the
neglected realm of particular others
in the actual relations and actual
context of women's experience
again she's mainly just talking about
women's experience but we i think we can
actually broaden this when it comes to
the ethics of care
first off let me ask you do you think
that this do you think she's onto
something i think that she's right that
this is something really important for
moral theory is that something that you
would want an ethics class to tell you
about
to give you to come out of the class
with some better insight into these
relationships that you have than you
came in with
if you say yes
then you agree with her
not only that this is important but that
moral theory ought to
focus on this
so i guess that'll be a test for this
class not not for you to take but for
you know when i give you the evaluations
for the class
moral theory must pay attention to this
this and to the actual context of
women's experience
she gives a few examples of this later
on and i'm only going to focus on one of
them
a different concept of the self she says
there's a way of thinking about selves
again where the relationship itself has
the primary value and the people in the
relationship
find themselves in it
she says this happens in mother child
interaction and are satisfied in
mutually empathetic relations
this doesn't require a loss of self but
a relationship of what she's calling
mutuality in which both self and other
express intersubjectivity both give and
take in a way that not only contributes
to the satisfaction of their needs as
individuals which is one thing right if
i'm in a relationship with you
i should give and i should take in a way
that fosters your good
that that helps you out
and i should also look out for my own
good too right it should just be giving
all the time i should also get something
out of it
but also affirms the larger relational
unit that they compose
maintaining this larger relational unit
then becomes a goal
so
this is you know when people talk in
other terms not about larger relational
units but when they say
our friendship matters
or
family matters or
if you're involved in romantic
relationships people then talk in terms
of relationship i'm concerned about our
relationship they don't just say i'm
concerned about me and i'm concerned
about you they talk about i'm concerned
about this thing that connects us
together the health of the relationship
the longevity of it whether it's a good
relationship or not
that has to become an explicit goal in
moral theory
held things
and then she says maturity is seen not
in terms of individual autonomy
just being able to you know direct
yourself call your own shots
but in terms of competence in creating
and sustaining relations of empathy and
mutual interceptivity mutual under
subjectivity that's kind of a
complicated thing but just think about
empathy
think about
experiences that you've had
where i think all of you have had we'll
just take professors right
i'm willing to bet that every one of you
has had a class that has given you
trouble
is that accurate maybe more than one
okay
if you go to go to the person's office
hours or you know talk with them or
something like that
so if a professor is actually empathetic
towards you
um what does that look like
does that mean they just say oh whatever
you need
you know they're sort of a pushover
that's not empathy
what does it look like
that's a good way to put it
um
they work with you they there's there's
a recognition of the value of you as a
person in doing that right and there is
some sense of allowing you autonomy
but it's trying to work towards your own
good your flourishing
treating you as a person that's valuable
yeah and and they also
can they tell
anything about the trouble that you're
having
they don't dislike you because you're
not understanding their great subject
that everyone ought to be studying or
something like that they understand the
difficulties that you're having with
them
and they they have some sort of not
necessarily having the same feelings as
you but you can tell that they
understand your feelings that's what
empathy
actually is that's something that takes
like she says competence you have to
develop that it's not something that
automatically comes to you in every case
maturity from this point of view the
ethics of care
would mean having the capacity within
this realm of relationships of
developing
empathy developing care for other people
you know when it comes to emotions the
two emotions that ethics of care is most
concerned about is care
and then this this whatever it is that
we call empathy
we might not necessarily see it as an
emotion but an emotional capacity
so that's where we'll leave a lot